no just father a thought is it gone yet
here you stand that best hope against
the coming storm
if we don't put aside our enmities and
band together we will die
lemon doesn't matter whose skeleton sits
on the Eiffel
[Music]
the Great Wall is he full the starts
ended up together again yes there be
monopoly and Scrabble and a nicely but
it would all kind of be a bit strange
and I after everything that they've gone
through I think it might be quite a
quiet dinner together or something it's
pretty awkward I don't think it'd be all
fun and games after everything it was
coming through they're all just one big
happy family
I think like at West Oak Street
I think the gold particle
I bet you just sit down and all the
stuff can now have a mail that didn't
end in one of them getting murders I
think you guys are messaging me all
about cat's paw Arya Stark reunion let's
break this down there's a bunch of stuff
that the trailer didn't show there's a
new round of the giveaway is for the
enhanced editions of the books all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
so if you're wondering with that
Entertainment Weekly video was about
they did a photo shoot all decked out in
Stark regalia so Arya is wearing her
Stark clothing so when they're joking
about stark reunion Oh we'd probably
just have a normal dinner you know one
where nobody got killed they're dressed
like that because these are actual
costumes from season 7 we'll eventually
see a form of a stark reunion that
doesn't confirm that they're all going
to be on-screen together at the same
time because you have Jon Snow who looks
like he's going to the north Arya
traveling from the south in Sansa looks
like she's the only person that's going
to stay put in Winterfell for most of
the season but let's chart the timeline
for all these characters and we'll start
with Arya Stark the really cool thing
that we all noticed when they posted
this giant high-res picture is that
she's wearing the Valyrian dagger that
cat's paw used to try and kill brand way
back during season one
remember Joffrey hired him to try and
get rid of him after he caught Jaime and
Cersei having sex in the tower he got
pushed to the ground he lost the use of
his legs when he went to assassinate
brand Catelyn was watching over him in
summer saved them so that was like the
big turning point for Catelyn with the
dire wolf she was like why the hell are
these things in here but summer earns
her respect and we never get
confirmation that Joffrey is the person
who hired cat's paw but he is this line
of dialogue much later where it says you
send a dog to kill a wolf so he puts two
and two together and says oh he must
have hired this cat's paw person but
where did she get this dagger from
obviously his badass that she finally
has her own balerion blade needle isn't
a Valyrian sword it was just a normal
sword that Jon had made for her before
they all departed Winterfell so the last
known whereabouts this is actually where
it starts to get really cool is actually
with Littlefinger he grabs it from Ned
Stark after he was arrested in season 1
in
throne-room you see him later after he's
taken salsa to the fingers eating a
piece of fruit with it
so obviously that happened during season
four of the TV show but that means that
Aria gets the cat's paw from a little
finger at some point during season seven
unless they do a big change to the plot
so we'll see how much that changes but
as Aria is slowly heading north through
the trailer you have to remember that
she starts way down here at the twins
the next big stop is actually greywater
watch which is the seat of house
wreathed so if we're going to see how
and read it's going to have to be at
some point during that but I don't think
that's going to happen then moat Cailin
is a little bit north of that we've seen
that a couple times on the TV show and
then unless she hangs a right and goes
to white Harbor is actually a straight
shot up to Barrow town and then to
Winterfell
so when we see her in this in here it
could be in Barrow town but I know a lot
of people saw this picture and they're
like hey this looks exactly like the
door at the end of the crossroads so
unless she's going to be jumping around
in time and space Varys style just like
rapid Westeros transit system she's
making a beeline for the north because
most of the trailer scenes that we see
her in there's snow all over the ground
and it gets deeper and deeper just like
she's heading up straight through the
neck in these woods right here so
obviously in none of these trailers
shots is she wearing this dark uniform
the stark leather she has some armor on
so at some point she arrives at
Winterfell or somewhere near Winterfell
gets this clothing and then gets the
cat's paw dagger so I think we're all
hoping here that Arya is the person that
actually ends up killing Littlefinger
that would be the greatest thing ever if
she helps Sansa out after whatever
reunion they're able to get but you see
that Jon Snow scene where he's in the
crypts next to the Statue of Lyanna
stark just putting him on the wall like
he's getting ready to kill him himself
it sounds like the voiceover that
Littlefinger has is actually him
whispering to Jon everyone around you is
that your father your brother's your the
last best hope so maybe he's trying to
get him to doubt himself but he's also
whispering to Santa here so the Jon Snow
later in the trailer shows up in the
frozen north and the lands of always
winter in these wildling furs on some
other mission then maybe while everyone
is back at Winterfell
Arya takes care of Littlefinger let me
know what you guys think about that
because
she'd only be able to get the cat's paw
from him and it's not like Littlefinger
would give up a Valyrian dagger of his
own free will the Jon Snow part is
actually really interesting so that
might be the intersection with bran with
his family because he's wearing furs in
this so at some point he makes it to the
wall that's probably where he gets some
better clothing but you see the gate at
Castle black go up like everyone's going
to be going back into the north the
reason for that I think is probably just
to grab proof of the White Walkers so
that they can convince Daenerys and even
Cersei herself like Davos says if we
don't put our differences aside we're
all dead
the Cersei part of that is a bit of a
stretch Daenerys is much closer she's a
much better choice for an alliance so I
have a feeling that Davos is speaking
this line when he's in the presence of
Daenerys but the problem is is that it's
just really hard to convince everyone of
a threat if you don't have any evidence
that's so far north that's beyond the
wall the wall is impenetrable the masses
of the South don't want to think about
what's happening beyond that wall they
don't care about any of those people
especially the wildlings the quickest
way to shut them up would be to show
them some form of white Walker even if
they just chop a couple limbs off they
don't have to bring them a full white
Walker they just have to bring them the
head look this is what's coming for us
the army of the dead Santa's got another
wardrobe change but really the biggest
ones are Arya in her stark gear just
kind of confirming where it is she said
it and then brand just confirming that
he's also headed south - so Jon Snow
looks fantastic especially in the armor
it's just a slightly nicer looking
version of the armor he was wearing at
the end of last season
remember salsa made him clothing that
looked just like their father Ned Stark
so when we talk about Jon Snow looking
more like his father we have to talk
about his biological father and we have
to talk about the father who raised him
he's mostly looking more like the father
who raised him but we haven't seen a
picture of Rhaegar on the series yet so
because george RR martin confirm that
they are not going to be doing a
Robert's rebellion prequel remember
there are five prequels that HBO is
trying to develop right now none of them
are Robert's rebellion meaning we'll get
all that story on the main series so
just brace yourself a Rhaegar flashbacks
but he's is physically looking more like
Ned Stark used to dress as well as Sansa
looking more and more like
Hatlen especially with the hair like the
way it parts up the way she wears her
clothing in the thing about Aria that's
really cool is they say that she always
favored Lyanna stark you look a lot like
Liana so what a coincidence that the
actress that they cast to play Lyanna
stark just happens to look like Maisie
Williams a little bit in real life so
there's a whole lot of stuff going on
here let me know what you guys think
about this stark reunion just remember
that it sounds like aria is going to at
least be having a reunion with Sansa
because the whole Littlefinger catspaw
Valyrian dagger and I would bet at least
Jon Snow in bran reunion because bran is
at the wall Jon Snow will be headed to
the wall because we see him running for
his life with tormund and the other
wildlings but if there was any confusion
when they're standing in the circle here
this is obviously all these people that
Jon Snow's with we don't have to get in
any spoilers about a big character
that's been missing for the last couple
of seasons showing up during some of
these scenes they're billing this is a
little bit of a battle of the bastards
scenario where they're surrounded by
White Walkers what happened at the end
of battle of the bastards it seemed like
this unwinnable scenario they were
completely surrounded until the Knights
of the Vale rode in and saved them so is
there in the lands of always winter
surrounded by White Walkers who has
something they can ride in and save the
day deus ex machina style
Daenerys just a theory there but you can
see the way they visually try to mirror
other shots like you see Daenerys and
Jon Snow here but there are only a
couple of things that could save Jon
Snow in these people from a scenario
like that with White Walkers are
surrounding them and that would be
dragons
but I will say Arya arriving at
Winterfell puts odds that all the star
children surviving to season 8 it pretty
good none of them are particularly high
on my death predictions list I
definitely think that Littlefinger is
going to be gone before season 8 but let
me know if they do get rid of him what
episode do you think it's going to
happen in because people are moving
really fast and it's not like Arya would
sit around taking a bunch of his [ __ ] so
what's going to happen next is I've
gotten a bunch of requests for specific
videos based on stuff that happened
during the trailer so I'll try to
address that in my next couple of Game
of Thrones videos my next one will at
least post by Sunday maybe before then
but now that we actually have Game of
Thrones stuff happening it'll be like
two to three Game of Thrones videos
per week sometimes more than that it's
something really big drops believe all
your requests in the comments below
congratulations to Martin Smallwood
you're the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details it was a new round in this video
I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a game of Thrones video so
you can click here to rewatch the
trailer and you can click here for my
Game of Thrones spin-off video thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys tonight